Canada is divided over a pipeline Prime
Minister Justin Trudeau's government has
purchased a pipeline project from Texas
based energy giant Kinder Morgan the
trans mountain pipeline which will pump
oil from the Alberta tar sands to the
Pacific coast is costing Canadian
taxpayers seven point four billion
dollars an opposition has been massive
activists have taken dramatic steps to
resist this pipeline now a Canadian
Court has halted construction because
the government didn't properly consult
indigenous groups but for many other
Canadians the pipeline means one thing
jobs does it make you sad you have to
collaborate with a big oil company not
at all how far are you willing to go to
stop this pipeline you know it's in my
blood not to stop Trudeau has repeatedly
positioned himself as a climate leader
and a friend to indigenous people
protecting our environment and growing
our economy are not opposing values why
are you guys still here because this is
on ceiling
so we run a berry farm in a town called
Delta and British Columbia and we got
tipped off that Prime Minister Justin
Trudeau's here for an event it's the
leader of the Liberal Party himself no
bees no Justin this is unseeded
traditional territory you're not welcome
here we're trying to get closer to ask
the Prime Minister question but there's
this huge crowd
it's an impossible situation Prime
Minister Trudeau British Columbia has
become the epicenter of the anti
pipeline movement protesters have set up
resistance camps near Kinder Morgan
construction sites it's not the first
time we've seen this kind of tactic in
2016 water protectors at Standing Rock
successfully delayed construction of the
Dakota access pipeline for months it
looked like the node Apple movement
would succeed but president trump
cleared the way for the pipeline after
taking office now the focus has shifted
north in 2013 Kinder Morgan announced
plans to build a twin pipeline next to
an existing one in order to triple the
flow of oil through Canada the backlash
was immediate after several lawsuits
Kinder Morgan threatened to walk away
unless Trudeau guaranteed a path to
construction in a widely criticised deal
Trudeau's government purchased the
pipeline for 3.5 billion dollars
promising it would boost the economy and
allow Canada's landlocked oil to be sold
to foreign markets for many it was a
slap in the face climate leaders don't
buy or expand pipelines if it's
completed Canada will increase emissions
a major step backwards for the Paris
climate agreement but tar sands
extraction actually produces more
greenhouse gas emissions than
conventional drilling does
[Music]
so we're headed to see the main
construction side of the Kinder Morgan
pipeline here in British Columbia and
because there's so much security
surrounding it really the only way to
get to it is by water William George of
the Tesla watu 'the nation is the leader
of the Coast Salish resistance here in
British Columbia how do you feel when
you look over there and you see how much
security there is and how much
construction there looks to be there's a
lot of motions tied into it you see the
big crane there from what I understand
there pile-driving in you know big steel
structures getting ready for these super
tankers so there'll be I essentially I
think four docks documents for these
super tankers to come in and then take
over I gets eight hundred ninety
thousand barrels of bitumen and the
thing with Mitchum in that not a lot of
people are aware of is it doesn't float
it sinks to the bottom you can't recover
it at all so I just again just another
reason why this is unacceptable and we
want to allow travel through our bodies
of water have you ever gotten in trouble
for getting this close no
I'm not allowed of 100 meters in any
compound often why I hung off there's a
bridge right there
so being a team we hung off there for 38
hours we stopped the oil tanker from
leaving here for two days this coastline
could see 21,000 oil tankers over the
next 50 years more tankers means more
noise which scientists say poses grave
risks for endangered mammals
how has Kinder Morgan's presence
affected the ecosystem here well right
now we have a mother Orca that's
swimming around for over a week and
she's pushing around her dead calf and
it it's really uncommon for them to do
that so in a way that they are telling
us something
these are supertankers or the size of
the Empire State Building and just that
noise pollution in the water alone will
ultimately put to extinction those orca
whales days before the government
announced it was buying the pipeline the
federal fisheries and oceans Department
sent a letter warning Kinder Morgan it
could face prosecution for putting
marine life in danger near an oil
terminal in Vancouver the company had
gone months without filing mandatory
monitoring reports Prime Minister
Trudeau came to office and positioned
himself as an ally to indigenous folks
and as a friend of the environment and
yet he's gone ahead and purchased this
pipeline what do you think about that
one fortunately I voted for the bugger
by him lying to us is it's upsetting in
so many ways when he promised to protect
our indigenous rights promised to be a
climate leader and he's doing nothing
about it absolutely just the opposite
really would you vote for him again no
just looking around and being on this
water it's it's stunning it's one of the
prettiest things I've ever seen yeah
yeah I'm gonna make sure it stays that
way absolutely
just outside Vancouver in Burnaby
protesters have set up two different
resistance camps watch house and camp
cloud watch house is operated by the
Tesla wata nation we're taking it back
to her old cultural teachings we would
have watch house locations and strategic
you know to watch out for the enemy you
know centuries ago and ultimately we do
see Kinder Morgan as the enemy in 2007
Canada endorsed the UN declaration on
the rights of indigenous peoples it
specifies that states and organizations
must adhere to what's referred to as
free prior and informed consent while
Kinder Morgan says it communicated with
more than 133 indigenous groups along
the pipeline route several First Nations
communities say they weren't properly
consulted it's devastating in every
single way this pipeline has got to go
Reginald Gillan's jr. is an activist
from Seattle who lives out watch house
how big is this anti pipeline movement
oh it's massive its massive you see this
happening all over the globe
disenfranchised communities are the
first to be affected by the effects of
climate change and extraction efforts on
mother earth Camp cloud is stationed
right across the street from Kinder
Morgan days before our arrival the camp
was served with an eviction notice black
wolf is from the Kwakiutl nation he's
been staying here for the past six
months
you guys got served with an eviction
notice not long ago yes we did so if the
city served you with an eviction notice
why are you guys still here because this
is owned ceded land we're federal
Indians means we don't have to listen to
the provincial levels a block or higher
up than they are we've had this law but
in since early 1800s you know this is
our rights as natives to be here when I
even protestors we're water protectors
land
but super what we like too because why
is this fight personal it's our food
chain we rely on all the salmon that are
coming and going from here it's going
through all the natural watersheds that
we have here what do you think of Justin
Trudeau's attempts at reconciliation
between Canada and First Nations I think
it was just ludicrous there is no
reconciliation going on there's so much
devastation to all first nations all
around BC it's not even funny let alone
even before this even happened 50% of
our native reserves still do not have
drinking water this is just not right
camp clouds occupants run what they call
surveillance operations to monitor
Kinder Morgan's activities and educate
the public about the pipeline this
summer the Federal Court of Appeals
delivered a major blow to the project
unanimously ruling the Trudeau
administration violated Canadian law
when it failed to properly consult
indigenous groups along the pipeline
route and that it did not consider all
the evidence regarding harm to the
environment our government inherited
flawed environmental review process we
made efforts to improve it now the
government must restart talks with First
Nations before construction can proceed
this is Canada's most active port
hundreds of ships pass through here
every day years ago you'd see even
larger ships in the water that is until
the Exxon Valdez oil spill in 1989 an
Exxon Valdez oil tanker bound for
Southern California struck a reef in
Alaska releasing 44,000 tons of oil it's
considered one of the worst human caused
environmental disasters in modern
history as a precaution Canada placed
more regulations on the oil industry in
2016 the City of Vancouver submitted a
report to the National Energy Board
claiming the risk of a spill along the
trans mount n'p I plan route is between
16 and 67% they argued this could cost
the economy hundreds of millions of
dollars and result in the deaths of
100,000 sea and shorebirds Carl and n
have lived in Burnaby for years they're
opposed to the expansion because they
say it'll bring devastating effects to
their
community I was driving home one night
and I started coughing really violently
I my car hit the curb I thought I was
gonna go off the road but he's madly
looking around to see if there was a
place to pull over there isn't it's one
lane going up the mountain and I saw the
tank farm and I thought well it must be
fumes from the tank firm and then this
happened three more times when this was
built nobody lived down this mountain
now there's residential areas all around
here down here and over here would you
say most residents of this city opposed
Kinder Morgan's expansion 75% chief
Ernie cray of the chamfers nation is in
favor of the pipeline and says his
community will directly benefit from its
construction are the members of your
nation in support as well as our
opposition there is opposition in my
community surprised there are some
people that are opposed to it for us it
means jobs money opportunities and a
better lifestyle from this time forward
well well well into the future we didn't
really get much advantage from the
earlier pipeline but we will from the
new pipeline because we support it and
we also have an agreement with the
company Kinder Morgan that offers us a
cash component and I can't disclose how
much money is involved that's part of
the agreement we've been hearing a lot
of different numbers about the jobs that
will benefit your community do you have
an exact number
well I think over overall there will be
thousands of jobs along the full extent
of the pipeline so there's nothing like
exact and guaranteed no I don't think so
the real jobs will come when we take
what we earn from the pipeline drive it
back into our own band own businesses
and businesses owned by our community
members and a lot of jobs will accrue
does it make you sad that in order to
lift your community out of poverty and
give them jobs and better benefits you
to collaborate with a big oil company
not at all
Canadians have benefited from the
natural resources including gas and oil
all these many decades and found a very
good lifestyle for themselves
split-level homes two-car garages
sending their children off to university
enjoying the good life for now the short
term goal for me is to improve the
economic and social standing of my
community and make them players in the
economy not people shunted over to the
periphery out of the mainstream out of
sight out of mind
we're not going back there folks is what
I tell white people and others we're not
going back there
we're not just talking about white
people there are several indigenous
communities who are vehement ly opposed
to this pipeline being built what do you
say to that I say that I understand
their opposition to me it's worth the
risk
do you feel that Kinder Morgan bought
off your community mm-hmm
no GM is not the pushover community were
were the tough men and women and we've
showed it repeatedly down through the
decades back in Vancouver resistance is
building these protesters have taken
one of the busiest intersections in
Vancouver it's a call for a stop to this
type line the day of the protest Kinder
Morgan announced that the pipeline will
cost billions more than initially
estimated we're out here because we want
to send a really loud really clear
message to the Canadian government that
we're not going to allow the pipeline to
be built and the people are still
committed to stopping it no matter how
many billions of dollars they try and
spend on it
Thomas Davies is a member of climate
convergence a grassroots organization
dedicated to fighting for climate
justice what's the significance of being
around all these banks well we just want
to interact with as much public as
possible the banks are big funders of
the tar sands in Alberta and
specifically the Kinder Morgan pipeline
before it was bought by the government
was financed primarily by big canadian
banks by for hundreds of millions of
dollars
days after we filmed that camp cloud
Supreme Court Justice Jeffrey Gomory
granted the city of Burnaby and
injunction ordering all camp structures
to be removed from outside the Kinder
Morgan tank form within 48 hours the
morning of August 16th Camp cloud was
evicted the Kinder Morgan protest camp
on Burnaby Mountain known as Camp cloud
is coming down eleven people were
removed and five were arrested the
injunction cited the camp's refusal to
put out the sacred fire camp cloud says
even though the camp is dispersed
they'll continue to monitor Kinder
Morgan's activities and resist further
colonization of their land
both Kinder Morgan and prime minister
trudeau declined to speak with us on
camera energy and indigenous sovereignty
are going to be key issues heading into
the 2019 election Trudeau still owns the
trans mountain pipeline and the
government is determined to see the
expansion through but for those who put
their bodies on the line to stop it this
is just the beginning how far are you
willing to go to stop this pipeline you
know it's in my blood not to stop I will
always mean you know that warrior for my
people do you think you'll succeed
absolutely you going up against your own
government I'm just one person with a
lot of supporters so I really do hope to
pray that I do succeed
hey guys it's Deena and that's what's
going on with the Kinder Morgan pipeline
here in Canada come back next week for
another direct from episode on the
epidemic of missing and murdered
indigenous women also here in Canada
make sure you subscribe to aj+
like this video share it and please
comment